today we're gonna see if people are
lying or not I think most people are
lying but someone's gonna toast to chuse
and one lie and it's our job to see if
we got it right or not what are some
good ways to tell it's a new life one
potential red flag is too much pausing
while they're talking another way is
actually verbal and nonverbal disconnect
so if someone's saying I didn't do this
and they're shaking their head like this
and they're probably lying another thing
would probably have to be covering your
mouth or your eyes with your hands or
even closing your eyes also a bad sign
is too much throat clearing or coughing
yeah if they get real gross and Flemmi
while they're talking to you it's
probably because they're panicking
another way to find out is if someone is
touching their mouth a little too much
when they're talking I mean I can barely
hear you what do you think if they do
excessive grooming like touching their
hair a lot anything that seems to be
like okay you already look fine yeah we
are going to try and apply these tips
and tricks to some people who may or may
not be lying to us and see if we can
tell the difference hello hello Chloe a
clue I was in beauty pageants as a child
I broken every bone in my right hand and
my great-uncle died from eating nothing
but boiled potatoes right off the bat
did you guys notice anything I feel like
she was very very deliberately reserved
to not be emotional and fluctuated
agreed I could see her face muscles
twitching like she was like holding
something back almost tell me about the
beauty pageant so you know toddlers in
tiaras mm-hmm
that was me were you actually on the
show no I was a little too old for that
when it came out I was already out of
the pageant circuit I started when I was
I believe four and I was out of it by
the time I think was 12 11 or 12 how
many pageants did you win I remember
there was one time that a girl didn't
come to the pageant because she knew
that I was gonna be there and I was
gonna win that was so quick see that has
to be true then she didn't even have to
think about her answer
she dreamed herself twice on camera and
look good she's a beauty pageant person
so how did you break your hand it got
ran over by a car it was actually my own
car this is horrible
my cousin was driving it and he was like
backing up or something and I had
dropped my phone and I went down to go
get it and he rang it over hand and
phone so the phone also was shattered
she was in LG NV - I don't want to take
for your hand - you and how long was
your physical therapy it was six weeks
for the physical therapy but my hand I
had to be in this cast that was so
stupid it was like all the way up to
here for the longest time I hated it who
signed your test first no one side my
cast I know it's because it was um you
know how you can get like the bright
colors mine was bright green and I
didn't want to sully it with any like
signatures or anything and your uncle
what about him
what's the story my great-uncle Gayle he
died from cirrhosis of the liver cuz he
ain't nothing but oiled potatoes where
was this in Valparaiso Indiana I think
more importantly when was if oh this was
probably 40s or 50s or something he also
started an urban legend in Indiana that
he saw a giant turtle that like turned
into this humongous thing they named it
Oscar the turtle and now they have
turtle days and Indiana dude
yes thank you oh no it's Churubusco
Indiana not Valparaiso
I apologize you're just throwing all
sorts of curveballs back here one of
those is a lie and all three are very
convincing super convenient like
logically though I don't know anyone who
lives off just potatoes was your
great-uncle a liar yeah yeah I mean he
did start an urban legend about toys so
it runs in the family
yeah yes interesting I think they're all
three lies my thought about the beauty
pageant was that she knows all these
details and they're like how many did
you win and she was like so many
I feel like like I had 13 first-place
titles to did it I'm like I feel like if
anything you'd remember specifically
would be like your wins mmm and that's
where she was a little fuzzy this is not
really a lot harder than I thought it
would be yeah I I'm gonna say the beauty
pageants a lot I'm gonna say giving your
hand right and I'm gonna go for the last
one and say that nobody can live up
potatoes all right the lie is I got my
hand ran over
I wondered because who doesn't get the
cast signed and no one had an LG n V -
oh why so yeah that wasn't rude yeah yes
I had it the thing about lying is you
got to put lonely nuggets of truth in
there hi hello tell us some supplies and
some truths if I feel like it so my
father invented clip-on sunglasses I
almost drowned in the Colorado River and
my uncle played trombone with the Beach
Boys the eye contact that you have is
amazing it was a very theatrically
delivered that's smart so tell me what
your dad how did you come up with the
invention so that means your child of
money right not necessarily
who does he own the patent for clip-on
sunglasses there are residuals did he
ever tell you the story about how he
mented it well he told me this that when
he moved into our house
he made a list of things he wanted to do
and one of them was build a a garden
build a darkroom and invent something
how did you almost drown whitewater
rafting I thought I could be cool and
not you do safety precautions and it
ended up being a category 5 day on the
river very strong current and
I didn't have my feet secured and
chiefed out of the out of the tube and
luckily I thought of all the cartoons
when they grab onto the rock and it's
about to go over the ledge so I grabbed
onto a rock was saved - you were about
to go over a waterfall no but it felt
like the raft leader found me who was on
the raft with you my family I've him the
stick memory of my dad sticking out like
the paddle so your dad helped you first
and the raft leaders the one that would
feed you right right from the rock
exactly you said safety I'm gonna have
fun that's your devil-may-care attitude
leather jacket respect too angry I'm
really believing the clip-ons just go to
the jacket tell me about your uncle what
was his name his name is Steve also same
name as my dad he's also a pharmacist
how do you have those two career up
paths there's a very different curve
either very wind up playing trombone for
if he was a pharmacist well he you know
people got a hustle you know you know
you don't always get the gigs he was
just like I'm a sexy phone play now I'm
gonna be a pharmacist that playing
trombone for the Beach Boys seems like a
hard job to fall into had he been
playing trombone his whole life he did I
think for most of it was he a licensed
pharmacist he must have been if he was
working at CVS well you can't argue as
CVS he also played with Fats Domino this
is a plug for my uncle right now listen
to his bands all right it's very safe
right now yeah oh he's a nurse he must
have went back to school class different
schools he's also so old at this point
because the Beach Boys are pretty old
that should he have a nurse being taking
care of him hey I mean I'm just saying
sure when was this when did he play
trombone with the Beach Boys
it was the leave early 70s I desperately
want the clip-on sunglasses thing to be
true just so I can say I've met you
agreed I really want to say his uncle
was the math doesn't add up because if
he's in his 60 and the last member was
in their 80s I think around the time
he'd have to be like
well look at his face he was upset that
that was the thing we were gonna choose
he was like confuse like don't poke
holes in my sin might one true the clip
on story also is very inconsistent
that's what I'm there it's too romantic
of a story I feel or like an idea I'm
gonna go with the journey I'm gonna
accept the details being fuzzier on the
uncle because I I can't tell you a lot
of details about my uncle's life so I'm
gonna say it's the clip-on sunglasses
although I desperately hope it's true my
lie this evening my father invented
clip-on sunglasses it ain't I'm just an
expert at reading people I flawlessly I
love the idea that your dad was like son
have a seat tell us your truth I have
nine piercings and no tattoos I've never
had a drink in my life I am Number four
out of five sisters I don't like the
specificity of that one cuz you could
just be three out of four yeah when did
you get your first piercing sixteen and
where's your first person first person
is with my belly did you get permission
from your parents to get these piercings
no aren't you supposed to be eighteen
tattoos and piercings are eighteen you I
think you have to have your parent how
did you circumvent that much I mean if
you're gonna hook up me what was your
heck I think that they yeah it was cool
like yeah yeah what place was that
Claire's
Elliot knows that it's how to shop and
you just got a hookup yeah you're just
like hey yeah it's pretty and you never
talk to that person again after so the
tattoo person yes yeah is there any
specific reason you haven't had a drink
didn't want to be under the influence
didn't want that life which one's given
us pause I have a gut instinct I think
it's the drinking one I feel like that's
such a commitment that there would be
like a reason they didn't want to be
under the influence didn't want that
life no repairing out her ears and I'm
not seeing anything and I might be
because of her hair I do have a question
about your sisters can you please give
me all five names and their ages
division or forties Chanel and her
forties so out her thirties me and um
sir Kyra it's already get sick I was
young I don't know that you're not my
initial gut was the drinking one I am
going to switch to piercing I think
piercings is also I only because she
thought of the names very quickly I also
think because I don't see it on her ear
so unless you pure rock n roll girl my
gut reaction was the sisters just the
specificity of four out of five just
like I've done that trick in the same
game so that's why I initially go
towards there and I will say it took a
little while to name your five sisters
yeah so I'm gonna go with the sisters
what is it it's the system can I
actually like talk to you off check so
really went nowhere
hello hello welcome I'm an only child
I love pickle juice and I have three
middle names
what are your middle names Brielle
Elizabeth and Anna how do you usually
enjoy pickle juice my favorite way to
enjoy pickle juice is with pickle Beck
so you got a shot of whiskey and a shot
of pickle juice but I have no shame if I
have a jar pickles and the pickles are
gone I'm sipping all that juice too so
salty potato chips
oh to be clear I desperately hope all
three of you were lying about that if
you had a sibling what would your
sibling be like a sister so I can share
clothes and makeup products I feel like
they would have to be younger anyone
notice any cues when she was telling her
lies initially I felt like there was a
brief hesitation before she said and
also she was like this this and and
Brielle Elizabeth and Ann and I was like
interesting does your sibling have one
middle name or three I don't have a
smart so smart
I think it's maybe the pickle juice I
feel like it could just be I actually
hate pickle juice and like that's the
flip I'm just gonna call my gut and it
could be a hundred percent wrong but I
think you do you have a sibling
okay I'm going pickle juice all the way
for the same reasons he is pickle
sibling pickle which is the line I'm not
normally sibling six I
[Applause]
ah I have two sisters and three brothers
and they're all younger than me what
made you because you know what y'all
it's a sister thing people always think
I'm an only child but I have an older
sister and a younger sister people may
think you're an only child but you just
have the vibe that you're all about your
family I think it was a learning
experience
[Music]